so i want to give you my opinion on
colon cleansing there's several
different types
you have colon hydrotherapy where you're
putting water
up through the rectum into the large
intestines
and then you're flushing everything out
okay herbal laxatives
create a purging of the material out
from your colon
then you have something called the
colema which is a combination of an
enema
and a colonic because you're using an
enema tube but you're also flushing
water up through here and pulling it out
this is that was developed by bernard
jensen i've done it
three or four times a very long time ago
the problem with that is that it's very
very temporary
i actually experienced a lot of good
benefits but the other problem is it
flushes
out your electrolytes okay and if you're
already deficient
you can feel very dizzy it can affect
your heart and even a colonic can also
flush electrolytes so you better make
sure you put those back
in so you're not deficient not to
mention you're also flushing out
your friendly bacteria you have to put
that back in there as well
because some people that get this done
end up with constipation because they
they just basically wiped out their good
bacteria and they haven't put it put it
back in
one of the problems with the colema is
that one of the things that
you're doing in addition to eating the
food is you
you are drinking apple juice and it's
going to keep that blood sugar up
you're going to feel miserable because
you actually never get into a state of
ketosis
because you're drinking this apple juice
causing your body to be dependent on
glucose
and not your own fat so you have this
constant crash in blood sugars
all i thought about and dreamt about on
this program was at the end of it i was
going to really
consume a large amount of pizza and
salty foods because i was so deficient
they didn't
really put back those electrolytes and
the apple juice was not a good idea
so my opinion is this why would you want
to do this in the first place
what problem are you trying to solve do
you have too many toxins in your
colon do you have ibs do you have polyps
maybe you have constipation maybe you
have malabsorption
problems even in the small intestine
maybe you have some type of
itis ilitis diverticulitis
colitis in the small intestine or the
large there's many different reasons for
for doing this but the first thing that
i would recommend
is you must fix your diet because what
you're normally going to find is if you
really fix
this these things are usually going to
go away
but i'm not against doing colon
hydrotherapy
maybe for a short-term solution for
constant patient
or other conditions but just realize
that it should be supervised and you
better put your electrolytes back in
as well as the frowning bacteria but if
you think long-term there's really two
things that you must do you must fix the
diet
of course you know what i'm going to say
you need to go on a keto diet
ketones have anti-inflammatory
properties
it's going to greatly help your colon
adding more carbohydrates adds more
inflammation to your digestive system
but the most important thing is to start
doing fasting okay intermittent fasting
why because the frequent eating goes
completely against
how our digestive system was designed we
were not designed to eat so frequently
we're cramming
so much food down this pipe where it
never has a chance to completely clean
out
where we're keeping our stomach our
small intestine our colon
constantly filled with food it
overwhelms everything
we get all sorts of malabsorption and
incomplete digestive cycles that's
really where the problem is so
this right here is a vital vital vital
if you're new to my channel
i put a link down below how to do it now
fiber
talking about vegetable fiber it can be
good or bad
most of the time it's going to be good
most people can actually do
vegetables without a problem the benefit
of that is
the phytonutrients that are very
anti-cancer
anti-polyp anti-tumor
not to mention anti-inflammatory and the
fiber
feeds the friendly microbes which then
make
a chemicals that are really good for you
that help
your blood sugars they're also
anti-inflammatory
however for some people consuming too
many vegetable fibers can tear up their
colon
in which case they need to go carnivore
for a while to actually
reduce that inflammation and reset
probably for about a couple months
and the last thing i want to mention is
fermented vegetables are very very
important now i want you to
differentiate between
pickled vegetables versus fermented
always get the
fermented if you are not familiar with
that i put a link down below of
the difference between the two but
fermented vegetables would be like
sauerkraut
some pickles are fermented kimchi very
very good because you have the
fiber and you have the probiotics all in
one
it's very good for the digestive system
all right that's my opinion and i'm
sticking to it
before you go if you have a question
about a product or you're new to keto
and you want to know how to begin keto
or you're on
keto and you need a debug because it's
not going as smooth
i have a keto consultant standing by to
help you
this is just for the people in the us
hopefully in the future we'll be able to
answer everyone's call
but i put the number down below so you
can call
and get some help